dans cette étude 30% des Français se
disent moins motivés qu'à la qu'avant la
crise sanitaire alors moins motivé dans
quoi dans leur vie quotidienne pour tout
travailler faire le ménage sortir faire
du sport c'est surtout vrai pour les
habitants de la région parisienne 41 %
se disent moins motivé pour les plus
jeunes les 25 34 ans et pour les
sympathisants de la France insoumise bah
oui 44% sont moins motivés contre
seulement 23% des électeurs d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la
vie alors je suis commercial dans une
entreprise qui développe des solutions
pour les cabinets d'expertise comptable
donc à base d'IA pour gagner en
productivité automatiser un petit peu
toute la saisie les comptables à la base
voilà ils se disent ça la manufacture et
si c'est la banque donc l'idée c'est la
travail une solution de pouvoir tout
autonome automatiser grâce à une machine
parce que les gens ont la même
motivation est-ce qu'au contraire vous
voyez des gens qu'on la flemme et qui se
replient sur eux-mêmes
oui je crois que ça existe déjà mais
c'est cool dans le boulot dans le boulot
en général je rencontre plein de gens
qui sont dans ce concept là pas
d'initiative donc pays pas initiative
pas dans l'herbe il serait temps mais
j'aime beaucoup ce nouveau concept
[Musique]
vous vous avez assisté de près à un
concours je crois même qu'on dit pas The
Voice mais on dit peut-être la voix au
Québec absolument puisqu'on aime la
langue française au Québec parce que
c'est votre sœur qui a participé à un de
ses concours on peut regarder de façon
très courte une de ces images on va vous
voir l'encourager vous êtes allés sur
place
[Applaudissements]
ça fait longtemps que vous chantez
depuis l'âge de 19 ans j'avais commencé
avec une émission télévisée chez nous en
Roumanie à la télévision nationale mais
bon plein d'émotions et tout on a 19 ans
c'est la première fois toute première
fois
on va se faire chier
[Musique]
gâteau
on préfère le ballon de rouge au ballon
rond
avec tout dans le nez ça passera mieux
la Coupe du Monde c'est sans doute la
vitrine de cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar
dressez face à la mer voici le stade
nine sevenfor construit entièrement à
partir de containers et de matériaux
recyclables il sera entièrement démonté
dès la fin du Mondial
face aux caméras du monde entier son
ingénieur vent une coupe du monde et
correspondable
[Musique]
nous sommes convaincus qu'en termes de
développement durable et d'héritage
cette Coupe du Monde établira un modèle
au niveau mondial et deviendra une
référence
est aussi le seul stade de la Coupe du
Monde ventil et naturellement notamment
par de l'air marin selon les Mira
mais toutes les autres enceintes de la
compétition dont certaines ont été
construites en plein désert seront
climatisés sur des vidéos de Tik Tok
comme celle-ci on voit des supporters de
l'Allemagne un des Bleus de l'Espagne ou
du Brésil qui sont très très chaud mais
qui sont surtout très très indiens
à un rituel avant chaque début de grande
compétition internationales
les cheveux de son entraîneur adjoint
qui s'appelle Guy Stéphane et donc qui
est d'accord qui est chauve mais on le
rappelle qui est chauve et donc ça veut
dire que ça sera une bonne compétition
voilà
très bien toutes ces personnes seraient
au fait des faux supporters vous avez vu
l'info un des figurants payés par le
Qatar pour faire croire qu'il y a de
l'ambiance dans le pays et apparemment
il y a pas que les supporters qui
seraient faux si l'on en croit la
présence de la star des Bleus Kylian
Mbappe ou
pour les associations de protection de
l'environnement climatisés à un stade
est une aberration la climatisation
génère des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui sont beaucoup plus nocifs que
le CO2 pour le climat des milliers de
fois beaucoup plus nocifs pour le climat
c'est une coupe du monde qui connaît
écologique est un non sens complet
sobriété énergétique hier en confe de
presse il a vu plein de portes ouvertes
mais plutôt que de les fermer il a
décidé de les enfoncer
il y a qu'une équipe qui gagne et en
Coupe du Monde c'est tous les quatre ans
gagner c'est très difficile on retient
que le que le champion il y en a qu'un
c'était dans une défense A3
voilà qui est qui est différente
d'une défense A4 ils ont l'esprit
olympique mal placé en découvrant les
mascottes des JO de Paris beaucoup
d'internautes y ont vu des clitoris les
montages photos se multiplient et les
blagues vont bon train apparemment la
majorité des hommes n'arrive pas à
trouver la mascotte pourtant rien à voir
les friges sont une référence au bonnet
phrygien quitte à choisir un symbole de
la révolution française pourquoi pas la
guillotine s'amuse des internautes en
créant guillotinou il faut quand même
être zinzin pour tout de suite
regarder ça sous le prisme
d'un organe sexuel ou du genre elles
sont vachement quand même
pas forcément
joyeux non
je crois que c'était des samoussas les
trucs